I don't believe that in a moral and
wealthy America people should be too
poor to live how are you feeling
can you put it into work no you are from
the Bronx born and raised you actually
represent and live in the community that
you hope to represent in Congress when
we see all too often Congress members
not even living in their district like
your opponent what does it mean for you
to have effective representation like
that there's been so many especially
working-class people in the Bronx that
are so excited I went to my bodega last
night and people were just excited and
clapping I think it just means a lot to
be seen and to feel seen and to feel
like one of you a representative from
your community that cares that stays
there has a voice in what's going on
most of your fundraising was small
donations and you refused to take
corporate PAC money why was that so
important to you I wanted to be a 100%
accountable representative to my
community I believe that the role of
money in politics is really degrading
our democracy and hurting our ability to
have effective government there's a lot
you can do without money you can knock
on your neighbor's door without money
you can make phone calls without money
and that's just what we did for a really
really long time as this race goes on to
the midterms do you see a scenario where
you're gonna have to start taking
corporate money and would you do it I
won't like I am totally fine working
with political organizations but the
line that I want to draw is pretending
that I am neutral in policymaking when
I'm taking money from
one side that has invested for profit
interest you're running on a
medicare-for-all free public college
Federal jobs guarantee which is the top
priority for you and how are you gonna
pay for this that's always a question
how are you gonna pay for it war is very
expensive too we never asked about that
we only ask how we're gonna pay for
things we're talking about taking care
of people
so GOP tax cut costs the United States
four hundred billion dollars you know
what you could have done with 400
billion dollars you could have forgiven
every single federal student loan debt
in America that's what you could have
done with 400 billion dollars we want
improved and expanded Medicare for all
we want to ition free public colleges
and trade schools we want a green new
deal to address climate change I'm an
idealist and my goals I'm an idealist in
my vision and I'm very pragmatic about
how I get there I don't believe that in
a moral and wealthy America people
should be too poor to live I find that
to be an unacceptable state you can be
too poor to see a doctor that you can be
too poor to send your child to the
school that actually gives them options
for their future and I want to live in a
society that does not fail people's most
basic needs to live and so that for me
is my
you know it's about dignity you call for
the abolishment of ice and I think a lot
of people forget that ice hasn't really
been around all that long it's was born
out of the so-called war on terror it's
been around since 2003 only but what do
you see as a replacement for ice I think
that immigration should be safe I think
that we should grant people a safe and
documented rite of passage Republicans
try all these scare tactics and they go
oh open borders you know because they're
trying to incite fear but what we really
need to do is demilitarize a lot of
what's going on in terms of the
detention of people which has been
happening for a very long time by the
way and so I think that that when we
talk about replacing it with a system
when you talk about really having a
system that is safe that documents
people effectively that is also not
rooted in the discrimination that our
immigration system was initially built
on the first immigration law in the
United States was the Chinese Exclusion
Act the first law about immigration in
the United States was how do we exclude
a specific type of people and our
immigration system has really kind of
evolved from that I think initial route
and I don't think it necessarily has to
be that way days before your election
you left New York and you went down to
the southern border to protest these
family separations that we're seeing and
you said the moral character of our
nation is on the line right now the
nation that we are living in is a
country and that and an administration
that has committed international human
rights abuses by separating children
from their parents
that is being done in our name once
something that extreme happens we have
to act immediately do you see any
parallels between the Muslim ban and
what's going on on the border right now
absolutely absolutely what the
administration is doing is racializing
the fight over immigration and that is
kind of stoking an increased sense of
bigotry in the country and so there's
absolutely a connection and that is why
I think we have to be in solidarity with
each other you've been outspoken in your
support for Palestinian Human Rights
which some would say is political
suicide for a New York politician very
uncommon for someone in Congress or
running for Congress you called Israel's
response to peaceful protesters in Gaza
a massacre in a tweet why was it so easy
for you to see it that way it's just not
about nationality it's about people who
are unarmed who are killed
if 60 people were shot and killed and
Ferguson if 60 people were shot and
killed in four Tirico if 60 people were
shot and killed in the South Bronx it's
tragic
it's tragic you're speaking directly to
work in class folks do you think your
message and yourself appeals to Trump
supporters just because I may be aghast
at the way that somebody voted does it
mean that I'm going to permanently
dismiss them I'm a woman of color that
comes from a working-class sometimes
even poor background depending on the
year and a vote for Donald Trump a lot
of times I could take it as a personal
rebuke of everything that I
but I just cannot give in to that
because I still believe that there's a
lot of people that could be won over on
that agenda on my agenda do you think we
can talk about class without talking
about race and talk about race without
talking about class no no there's this
false notion that you can separate these
two issues there's a false notion that
you have to pick one or another and it
is patently false this is the United
States of America we have to confront
our history we founded our nation on an
economic system of slavery that has
evolved to Jim Crow laws it involved
into mass incarceration there is no
economic issue in the United States that
does not have racial implications and
vice-versa you look at issues like
immigration you look at issues like
criminal justice reform private prisons
they all have economic implications and
the idea of saying oh we need to talk
about class and not race is to also
erase the identity of many people it's
not like only one class creed religion
of person is working class so it's
clearly a dark time for a lot of people
in the country especially young
progressives who have just been seeing
you know a lot of doom and gloom since
Donald Trump was elected president what
do you say to two young people to give
them hope and to get them engaged
wherever there is a fight there is hope
when people stop fighting that is one
hope nuts
and I think that's what we proved on
Tuesday that no matter the odds change
is possible in America and that our
nation is never beyond repair
[Music]